are you doing today sir terrific farm
really sparkling I am super happy you
came in today I'm a big fan of your work
oh thank you and I really enjoyed State
of the Union I'll cherish stave so
what's interesting about this is in this
era of like crazy television it this is
an unusual show because it's ten
episodes at ten minutes each
that's right yeah it's unusual I think
it's the future of TV I think we're
coming from a world where people of a
certain age are watching all of their
stuff and five minute content on YouTube
so eventually content will probably
become a little bit shorter just because
we're so used to shorter content well
the thing about but the internet and
just content general is there TV was you
know designed is 30 minutes to to sell
commercial that's right and now there
shouldn't be I mean in my opinion it
should be the link should be the length
what it needs to be that's right and I
suppose now that it we're also not
beholden necessarily to network formats
and everything is more Streamy it's it's
going to be more fluid a lot of like
water analogies going on here but yeah
but more importantly this is it's an
interesting show because it's the ten
minutes before a couple go into marriage
therapy every week so I think watching
any more than that would be just
gruesome I definitely want to go
backwards and and find out how you first
got involved all right you know what I
did a film called Juliet naked which is
awesome that with Nick Hornby who sadly
can't be here today because he hates you
he weirdly is a gymnastics coach wait
what yeah I don't know if you know this
about Nick
he's a very such a smart guy but also
he's a part-time gymnastics coach back
in England and he had a big championship
today so did the boys and girls had a
big thing it's an underage gymnastic but
he's gonna try and come in tomorrow and
see how's people place but Nick and I
had worked together on Juliet naked and
I got a call from either him or Stephen
Frears who I worked with before on
the Lance Armstrong cycling thing and
just keep on dropping names because
Steve directed to like I met him at a
party but so they asked if I was
interested and and I was because I'm
such a huge fan of rah spike who plays
my wife in this and so it all came
together quite quickly I am the thing
that people won't know until they see it
is that the abundance of dialogue that
takes place in this series and I'm I was
watching it and I just couldn't help but
think to myself how the f did you
memorize all this because it is non-stop
back and forth between the two you know
I usually like a question that you get
as an actor from norm of paper is how do
you learn all the words and 99 times out
of 100 it's not hard it's just because
you don't film that Moche only film five
or six pages a day at most if you're
doing affirm and there's lots of what
they're people talking and it's not that
big of a deal I mean TV show I mean I'm
a lead on a TV show now and it's not a
Tyler but it's totally manageable this
was the hardest I've ever had it because
it is it's it's kind of twelve pages
everyday and then you finish the end of
the day and you realize you have 12
pages again the next day because we film
one Episode a day pretty much so I want
to pause there and just say as someone
who saw the show I am blown away you did
in episode today I don't I don't
understand how you did it yeah was I
doing a short player one-act play every
day but I came on board probably last
and Roz was so prepared by the time I
got there I really had to keep up but it
was good you know it was she's what we
call talented she seriously is and I
didn't want to let her and everybody
down so we kind of I think we did we did
relatively well sometimes you kind of go
into autopilot and it's sad because you
realize for momentarily you're thinking
about the words rather than the
performance or whatever but I think you
get away for you get away with it for
the most part you must've had all the
scripts before filming again yeah so how
early did you have the scripts and
you advanced looking at all ten and
trying to get like a backbone done there
was some of that there was also weird I
just had a baby so it was a lot of time
at home trying to learn lines that kind
of 3:00 in the morning doing feeds and
things like that but I probably I
probably had it down within a month I
probably learned all the lines and then
oh the whole thing yeah I mean like each
night was just sort of a refresher yeah
so talk a little bit about filming you
filmed in one location basically in the
therapists offices across the street how
do you remember how they decided on that
location and what it was like filming
there each day I guess they liked the
lies in there more than anything else
you know it is a trick but it's true
it's true it's to make something look
filmic and for the image to be pleasing
for such a long time when you're not
moving away from it really I mean it is
a lot of just back and forth it has to
have a nice light and this pub did have
this beautiful windows out onto the
street it was a typical Victorian bar
which seemed at keeping with the with
the work and yeah so we would go back to
that bar every morning and nothing like
arriving at a bar at 7 a.m. and always
perks you up oh yeah it was a what I
mean this is probably but I'm sure it's
non-alcoholic but at the end of each day
are you like yet just hand me the real
beer yeah we would actually we got into
this lovely routine Roz and I of
obviously add the beer is non-alcoholic
at the end of the day we would always
have a bottle of wine and learn the
lines for the next day oh that's great
yeah I mean there has to be like I would
imagine in that kind of situation the
the two actors you guys really have to
get along yeah to pull this thing off
because it's such a two hander it would
have been very tricky if we hadn't and
luckily like rods very easy person to
get along with and and fascinating and
smart and so professional and and funny
I didn't realize how funny she was
before we did this I'd seen her in a
couple of things where I thought oh I
didn't she's she's got some comedy chops
like is it an education oh yeah I think
she's in that yeah I don't know I don't
know how funny she is in that I
how many performances more private war
but Nick I think also Ron Rose an
education I think that's how they use
each other yeah
but anyway so yeah we got on grit which
made it a lot easier talk a little about
the drink of choice because you're
sitting there in that bar yes you're
drinking a beer I don't know what the
beer was I am curious who's an ale
do you remember what it was oh you know
I do actually it was a London pride
which is a very common British ale I was
wondering if there was any debate on
using Guinness yeah there was and I
think I probably would have said no
quite quickly only because it's I always
worried about me drinking Guinness in
scenes just feels like even though it's
true to life maybe it's just to
stereotype I
I learned this is so off the rails but I
learned with guitar you a big Guinness
drink you're so I'm a big fan also I've
learned that the further away from
Dublin the worse it tastes that stayed
common perception I don't know I I used
to work in a bar in Paris and and I've
worked in lots of bars in Dublin and
people used to say that our Guinness
wasn't great in this bar in Paris which
made me very angry
and we had had the Guinness guys come
around and check the pipes and do all of
that and we were importing the booze
from Ireland so it's the same drink and
then I went back to working in bars in
Ireland I realized all the difference
that special flavour is that they clean
the pipes much less by the way that's
probably true and also disturbing I know
but it does taste better I don't know
why I all I know all I learned I went to
Dublin recently and I learned that if
you never order the half pint always
order the pint even if you're not gonna
finish it because the top half is always
going to taste the best yeah that's true
you know and also you have to wait two
minutes for the drink because you gotta
let it set up and anyway if you haven't
drank Ennis I strongly recommend it
what when when you got offered something
a project like this talked a little bit
about it is it one of these things where
you're debating it or are you sort of
like oh I'm doing this you know what I
mean with more
than anything when you read it and you
end up and the other players involved
you're like oh yeah this is a no-brainer
and then it's just the scheduling and
all that kind of stuff and so I move
into London for a while and all of that
becomes a thing because I live in
California so there's a bit of that but
from a creative point of view it was it
was a very easy decision talk a little
about the way you like to work I've
spoken to a lot of actors that love
doing like like there furth they like
filming the rehearsal a take or two and
then they're like yeah that you've got
my best stuff and others love the
Fincher method of doing like 50 takes
and keep on going it depends what the
project is you know this was funny
because we were doing 12-minute takes
like we do the whole thing so you
definitely want a few goals out of it
but then that takes up your whole day
you know it's yeah I'm on five takes
that's an hour just to film which is
very unusual for the most part I don't
like doing loads it takes probably four
is by sweet spot right do you run out
it's like you start hitting like the on
take [ __ ] you know what I mean kind of I
I feel like I do a lot of prep so you I
arrive at set with a fair idea of what
I'm going to do and I've probably got
two or three different versions of that
and then another tip with the director
and then what else is there when I used
to do an awful lot of comedy I would
like more because there was so much more
improv and so I'd have a few ideas up my
sleeve or things would come to you and
what if you work with Judd Apatow or
whatever ends up being seven or eight
takes all right there than three or four
because it is just new ideas all the
time they actually new dialogue yeah I
find it fascinating with with judge
working because he gets such great
material on set I just can't imagine
what it's like to have to pick between
two awesome takes that are completely
different he's what he but he's
brilliant odd as well he's such a great
contributor on his feet I came calling
out stuff from behind the camera it
doesn't deserve to be as good I don't
know how much prep he has I can't I
meant to ask him that whenever I sing
but if he comes up with alternatives her
lines before we shoot the scene or if
he's coming up with that on his feet
because some of the stuff he comes up
with on the hoof is really
quaked and funny that's why he's joking
yeah yeah yeah
my hot take were there with that Judd
Apatow is funny your before I run out of
time with you we've been playing
something called get to know your
Sundance attendee with everyone coming
through okay it's just harmless
questions what TV show would you love to
guest star on you know what I'm really
into at the moment a succession a lot of
people are is that right yeah good yeah
what else Sesame Street obviously you
have kids
Yeah right right but by the way I'm the
reason to do size of my street is just
to be even a better dad I know you know
cuz you how many kids I have to I think
you know I've seen a few movies that let
me know that could be yeah I'm gonna
jump off do you have a favorite sci-fi
or fantasy film I don't know if this
counts but I'm gonna name one because I
felt like it deserved a better audience
when it came out was I like um Vanilla
Sky
ooh Cameron Crowe yeah sure I guess it's
more sci-fi off the mind but I liked it
sure
do you have a favorite superhero film do
you watch any the superhero movie I
don't but I like Superman to when he has
all the evil people come down from the
other place sure
Zod yes yes completely what films scared
you as a kid I've watched jaws before I
should have sure can you do you go
swimming or you're like that still
affects you not so much
that's a big lake swimmer exactly um do
you collect anything I don't really I
used to collect your key bar wrappers
your key is a chocolate bar in Ireland
and England and for some reason I like
the wrapper so I kept a few of them and
I put them up on my wall in my bedroom
and and then I kept collecting them and
eventually I had a Tao
of them I would go to shops and ask when
they were like throwing out the ones
that had gone out of days and I would
get the orchid by wrappers and this is
up till 5 years ago this was I gave that
up at the Millennium ratings I was all I
was thinking as you saying your key bars
am i cute they have like a willy wonka
thing going on there and maybe you're
looking for the golden ticket I can't
remember what it was like to cut my
father was like a sign writer so we a
lot of logos his workshop different kind
of iconic looking symbolism do something
about the Yorkie one that I found quite
interesting do you remember your first
movie or TV show crush oh gosh maybe
Neve Campbell on party of five that the
right show yeah yeah that was a big one
uh do you own any movie or TV show props
oh gosh I don't think so do I know I
don't think so
what's the background photo on your
phone it's like the the bit where you
haven't touched it is my baby and the
one where you were the not like locked
screen is my toddler okay what TV show
have you watched all the way through
more than once The West Wing I hear that
from a lot of people have this Aaron
Sorkin guy and 30 rock yeah picking out
these good people you have talented yeah
this is a this or that there's three of
these Star Wars or Star Trek Star Wars
game of thrones or Breaking Bad oof I
know that's tight it's very I probably
go for breaking pies if you've watched
all of Game of Thrones yeah do you have
a theory on how it's gonna end
no I think it will end Wow
I have I think the wildest thing that
could happen is at the end they just
sign a treaty I think that you know we
all got something that we wanted and
they're kind of coming out and speaking
to the masses and they're like look it
sometimes you just have to compromise
that is definitely how the show is going
to end percent Han Solo or Indiana Jones
Oh God to do what you if you could only
one of those characters I don't know how
I'm gonna phrase this but it's like
which one you know you're on a desert
island it's I'm gonna go with the one
with the plane I think so I think
they're both quite strong aren't they
yeah I'm gonna go with Indiana I think
okay the worst job worst job you've had
oh I've had a few buttes I was a pot
washer for a good while that's not that
fun but once I worked for an events
company where I had to dress up as the
Easter Bunny and it was for a very
well-known chocolate brand but it was
like a corporation thing where they were
releasing what Easter eggs they were
gonna have out that year but a Christmas
because that's when the trade papers
were gonna be talking about it so I had
to dress up as the Easter Bunny and like
execs would come and sit on my knee and
have a picture taken sounds like you
love and it was clearly after a boozy
lunch on their behalf so it was got
quite quite gropey I know you you
obviously you work a lot what are you
excited about that's coming up for you
that you can mention we're about to
start filming get shorty season three
congratulations by the way it's hard to
get a one show on the air let alone two
and three seasons I know it's pretty
sweet
so I'm looking forward to that and I'm
really looking forward to people seeing
state of the union because I think it's
very special my last question for you do
you remember what it was that made you
interested in the entertainment industry
did you see like a performance or a play
and you said I really want to do that I
think what I saw Boogie Nights for the
first time I was kind of struck as like
this is something very special the way
the Paul Thomas Anderson creates Carrie
usually I would watch movies and really
enjoying the but not see myself in them
and then you kind of see john c reilly
and Boogie Nights and Philip Seymour
Hoffman and that kind of new breed of
actors that seem to fuse humor and
naturalism together so deathly that
became something to aspire to
I that movie is fantastic I sincerely
hope that everyone Tunes in for State of
the Union wooden beam when can people
see it real soon leave it there and say
thank you so much for coming in
sincerely and a huge thank you to Kia
Telluride for being such a great sponsor
it's the only reason we get to be at
Sundance and do interviews like this so
thank you so much Kea thank you again
for coming in pleasure thank you